[Musique]
il
quenet
la ressource semble inépuisable elle est
pourtant précieuse chaque jour avec son
camion grumier frédéric parcourt les
chemins forestiers pour alimenter la
syrie qui l'emploie cela fait maintenant
une vingtaine d'années qu'il cueille les
grumes après le passage des bûcherons
le mieux est de plus en plus parce que
le bois se transporte de plus en plus
loin chacun s'est spécialisé dans une
naissance et donc le bois voyage d'une
plusieurs plus loin plus est ça s'abîme
très vite
donc dès que la chaleur augmente au
dessus de 10 degrés le bois a tendance à
s'échauffer c'est-à-dire compères de la
qualité dans les extrémités
donc là ils seront débités dans la
semaine ou la semaine prochaine
et après suivant les utilités ils seront
aussi rapidement quoi
certains des bois transportés par
frédéric ont peut être été façonnée ici
dans l'atelier de monsieur deschamps
benoît
il est l'un des rares artisans
aujourd'hui en franche comté à proposer
toute une gamme de meubles
il a succédé à son père qui a créé
entreprises au milieu des années 60
pour y arriver
la plus belle de faire c'est plus facile
d'acheter et de revendre que deux
fabriquée entièrement et deux arrivées à
la demande du client de satisfaire
entièrement du début chez lui on a su
préserver des métiers qui ont souvent
disparu avec l'industrialisation du
secteur du meuble
votre métier vous l'avez appris ou ici
voilà je suis riche je suis venu j'ai
été apprenti 6.80 et je suis resté ici
on est plus beaucoup à faire ça non non
non
moi je fais un meuble je fais de rased
jeu le fond je tanne giverny a très peu
maintenant qu'il nous faut encore un
grand jeu de mécano qui permet à ceux
qui travaillent dans cet atelier de voir
l'avenir avec optimisme le plaisir de
voir ces planches qui sont la mort de
l'été donne était morte et aisée pour
après arriver à les mettre à l'aise et
voilà que
là vous voyez la cuisine qu'elle a vous
dit que c'était l'époque étaient à bord
ce que ça super
c'est ça qui me plaît c'est et au
confort de rien d'une simple planche
était complet comme des pommiers belle
salle de bain et cuisine
[Musique]
frédéric le grenier s'apprête lui à
livrer le chargement de son camion à la
syrie génère qui se trouve à luxeuil les
bains
[Musique]
non
demain nous verrons comment cette
entreprise familiale qui appartient
aujourd'hui à une coopérative a su
s'adapter aux besoins des fabricants
demain
[Musique]